[Music]
jordan's in houston texas hi jordan how
are you
doing well thanks for having me guys
great man what's up
all right man so here's my situation i'm
curious about where my business loan
falls into
my debt snowball and i'm kind of
struggling with some guilt that i've got
over
not being able to give 10 to my church
and just how to manage those two things
together
how much is your business loan
90 000. who do you owe that to
um i oh it's a private loan so i
actually borrowed it from a family
member
okay
and so you signed a personal note right
correct yeah yeah so it's really a
personal loan
okay that you used for business
correct okay and um
what's your profit on your business look
like a year
um so last year so i bought a gym um a
week before the shutdown in march 2021
um great timing
next week hey you're done and so with it
being a small gym to its relationship
based and so everybody with all the
change and the fear
that was the first thing to go
um
so anyway that said it you know we went
down to nothing for that year um
i think i lost money in 2021 and then
last year
i did about 40
um profit-wise and so we were just just
able to make buy
um at home and so i really don't have a
lot actually i don't have any extra at
the end you know we're following baby
steps or doing our best to and and
cutting back you know at-home expenses
is there any other income coming into
the house all the things
yeah so my wife works as a teacher
and she makes what
she makes 52. okay so you you're making
40 off the business today and she's
making 52 off the business today
wow
how's the growth coming putting the
income back what did what was the high
point on the gym what was the best it
ever did
um that was actually back in august um
i did we did 17 that month
um but that was the highest it's ever
done
so what happened
what's that what in relation to small
relationship based gym i wouldn't expect
it to fall off
that next month like that what happened
in september
oh no so the next month it was just
about 1500 under that i think we were
right at fifteen five okay okay so it
wasn't a big drop off
no and we still haven't had a big drop
off currently we're just at a point
where
you know i'm making enough to pay for
expenses at home but nothing extra
and i'm making enough you know at the
gym to pay my
staff to pay the bills keep the lights
on but nothing extra like i don't have
any extra
you know fluff in in the budget
whatsoever now back when the before you
owned the gym
what did it do
oh we was doing like
7 000 a month
and you did 17 000. so you've doubled it
correct
yes and you paid how much for it
90
and it wasn't even making money
um no it wasn't it was breaking even
okay
so you overpaid dramatically
correct
um
wow
okay so we're going to continue to fight
it and get the uh and get continue to
get the income up continue to
work the business and i'll try to
increase your income out of the business
as much as possible
and what did you uh what'd you make at
your job before you took this jam on
um i made about 52.
okay all right so are you maxed
what's that is the gym max is the gym
max
no it's not maxed okay no i can i can
probably double it again before we get
to the max point okay all right let's
keep working to double it then and
that's going to be the answer to working
yourself through this and the business
loan goes into the debt snowball which
also means it's probably the largest and
it's the big thing at the bottom how
much other debt have you got
zero no so this is it okay
yeah so yeah i think you'd fight this
tiger and
if you could make 90 000 bucks extra in
um
in two years and pay it off
in other words increase your income by
that much by doubling which is what
you're talking about
um then you're out of debt in two years
if it takes you longer three years
that's fine but you get this monkey off
your back this thing suddenly starts to
be a lot more fun to run agreed
agreed yes and
can i ask about the giving during this
process yeah sure
you know
i'm struggling with this concept of you
know i want to be able to give to the
church and i feel like i'm not trusting
enough to give you know because i know
the tide is supposed to come off the top
all that good stuff but at the same time
i don't know which bill i don't pay if i
give that 10 percent
well i i would challenge you that you're
not that close on your
budget it just feels like you are
um because you're down there fighting
cash flow every day and so you've got
this sense of
that i've i've just i've done been doing
budgets for 30 years and very seldom is
somebody within 10 of being broke
it's just it's usually a lot worse or a
lot better
and so um this is about budgeting it is
about writing it down now what i would
challenge you on is the struggle part
okay number one uh i don't believe in
giving money the church i'm believing
give my god
and the as an evangelical christian the
first 10
he teaches us to give is to the local
church but uh i would change my phrasing
on that because it changes your heart
when you change your phrasing
you know the church really doesn't need
your money god really doesn't need your
money he wants to teach you to become a
giver
and he loves you
and so he's not wringing his hands
over you giving or not giving it's just
like if you have a kid and you look at
your kid and you say hey brush your
teeth you get to keep them that way
that's a loving father
right
and the kid's like yeah dad but i don't
really want to or dad it's not
convenient right now i'm a little too
busy i don't have the bandwidth um
you're like i know but when you don't
have any teeth someday you'll wish you
had brushed your teeth and this is a
loving father giving instruction to his
kid that he's crazy about do you hate
your kid or think less of your kid or
think your kid is got some kind of issue
if they don't brush your teeth no he's
just a kid and kids don't brush their
teeth sometimes adults sometimes don't
give
but your your heavenly father says son
the best way to live your life is to be
a giver
and jordan can i challenge you on
something
sure how much of this is a guilt about
giving and how much of this is guilt
over taking out that loan and overpaying
for a business
there's definitely some of that too i
think more so um it's it's
you know
not providing through you know a way
that i thought i was going to be able to
provide there you go and it's more so
for my family not not necessarily about
overpaying for the business and it's all
of it but here's the deal
you cannot move forward if you're
carrying that bag of bricks around with
you
and so at some point you have to make
the choice and it's hard and it's
something you practice but you got to
make the choice to say i did x
and that day is over and here's who i'm
going to become moving forward and i'm
going to start practicing those things
the giving part rallies around an
identity man it's like dave would say it
rallies around who you are who you're
giving money to i think you just beat
yourself up so bad and then you think
man i can't let another dollar go out
this door that's not feeding my family
because of what i've done to us and you
got to put that crap down man yeah so
the way i talk to myself about it is i
go sometimes i do stupid things but i am
not stupid there you go
so i think we can put you buying this
business under the heading of stupid
stuff or at least what you paid for it
uh but you're not stupid i've been
talking to you for quite a few minutes
you're anything but stupid you're caring
you're loving i think you're probably
developing into a really strong good
businessman
and i think you're going to have a great
thriving business it's going to take you
some time
and you're you'll never borrow money
again
and you'll never overpay for anything
again you've learned your lesson
and just like you know just like the
bible says borrowers slaves the lender
so get out of debt okay i don't want you
sitting around fretting and going i feel
awful i feel awful i feel awful but i do
want you to feel awful enough to get out
of debt that's right and the same thing
about giving i don't want you to be
guilted into it
or act like you're some kind of
christian boy scout or something doing
your duty but just go hey my heavenly
father who cares about me says the best
way for me to keep my teeth is brush
them
the best way for me to live is to be a
generous person i'm gonna work
generosity into my plan even when it
doesn't feel like it fits i'm gonna
practice it